guys welcome to the hustle well welcome
to the journey you know I'm homeless
right now you know it the YouTube
mastery course by human nor I is not
really working out for me and you know
I'm trying to I'm trying to make it I'm
trying to build a story build a hustle
build a journey you know it's all about
that it's all about the grind it's all
about sacrifice but um with that being
said guys I do only have one quarter in
my pocket right now which doesn't seem
like a lot but it's gonna be a big deal
when I'm telling my story I'm some TEDx
stage and you may be wondering why did I
fake being homeless for Klout and I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna be honest I'm
gonna be transparent with you it was a
calculated decision to build my story
and end you know better my online web
presence so here's the thing you know I
can talk all day about how hard I work
how I never sleep how I work 10,000 days
out of the year 12 hours per minute and
you know it doesn't mean that much to
you guys until you compartmentalize that
into a story I need I need to tell you a
story and the problem is I don't have a
great story so I've been learning from
people who are online who also don't
have great stories who are trying to
reinvent themselves as as poor you know
people who are started from the bottom
now they're here and you know as you
guys know I'm one of my big mentors the
people one of the people I really look
up to is human nor I or human TV the guy
who does gold digger pranks now
unfortunately he did block me on Twitter
after I was complimenting how he was
faking being on Ellen for Klout how how
cool that was and how unique that was
I'm actually working my Photoshop team
is actually working on getting me on
Ellen right now as well which I'm pretty
excited about but you know I didn't just
take that as a lesson from human you
know I also realized that you have to
have a great story he's was the person
who taught me that because after all
whom in TV talks about how he was
homeless in that sales video that's now
been deleted from the internet just four
years ago I was homeless sitting in
front of downtown Elias train station
with just $17.25 crumbled in my pockets
and at first it was discouraging to me
because I thought
how can I ever compete with a story like
that well the story is not as he
described it instead instead of being
homeless instead of having nothing else
to do he voluntarily left his parents
house because he was mad at them a
little apparent at the time and they
were just her parents they're like yo
you gotta go to school get a degree to
make you know I was homeless for four
days because I just couldn't take that
[ __ ] anymore
I'm leaving and not only that he wasn't
homeless for that long I was homeless
for four days at which point he decided
to go back to his parents house then I
realized like I can't do anything
without my parents without no money so
I'm back sorry this is kind of a far cry
from I was homeless and had no options
and I realized you know man I could do
that too I could I could leave my house
for a little while and you know become
homeless and over time he can just
transform that story from I moved out of
my parents house because I was annoyed
at them and then moved back in with him
after you know I realized they had money
and I didn't and I was basically relying
on them and you can transform that into
I was homeless and grinding and hustling
and I had nowhere to go just four years
ago I was homeless because I just
couldn't take that [ __ ] anymore I was
like young I'm leaving I grew up in a
very poor family my father was a drunk
and would always look for an excuse to
give me a beating so they're like no you
gotta go to school get a degree I'm like
no
yeah become an engineer my whole
families are dentists lawyers
I'm the only I'm the only child who's
not go to college in the past like
thousand years in my family trees so and
so when I realized that I realized it's
a game changer it's a total game changer
which is why I'm making this for you if
you're someone like me who wants a
hustle story but has absolutely nothing
to to complain about but you can you can
reformat your life to make it sound much
more sympathetic so what I decided to do
was to go to a into a box for two hours
in my back yard
I used a craftsman box I think we got it
at Home Depot that was my home for two
hours thank you for keeping me safe in
about a year from now I'm just gonna
change that from like I was homeless in
a box voluntarily and I'm gonna say I
was homeless I had nowhere to go you
know and I'm just not gonna mention the
time frame it was on because that is a
little bit embarrassing that it wasn't
able to do it much longer I was shooting
for three hours only could make two and
you might be thinking to yourself wow
that's a scumbag move to be exploiting
people who are homeless but I just don't
think you understand how you know
entrepreneurship works man we're all
about to fake it till we make it club
and anything to you know exploit us
entrepreneurs we're up for it I mean
take Austin Allred he is the CEO of
lambda school now this guy is another
voluntarily homeless character so when
he was doing his startup he voluntarily
became homeless and moved into his car
now as time has gone on that's
transformed from you know I was
voluntarily homeless and it's turned
into a Jessie I'm also formerly homeless
and the co-founder of lambda school you
know you just drop the voluntary part
and he just becomes homeless
if you change the narrative eventually
you can fake it till you make it so
that's what I'm doing I'm gonna go
finish my two-hour class I've actually
been breaking it up into chunks so I'm
gonna go figure finish my two our
homelessness streak two hours later and
just surviving is the hardest part so
you know I'm about about two hours into
homelessness and I think honestly I
can't take any more I'm gonna go back
inside
[Music]
hey I'm finished being homeless
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]